peter's bought a team in the 10th league
he's basically putting it on a bitcoin
standard he's gonna uh raise a bunch of
money he's gonna buy bitcoin put on the
balance sheet he's gonna improve the
team hopefully fingers crossed the team
continues to move up get the promotions
and then eventually by the time you get
towards the top leagues you've got a war
chest which helps you get better
managers better facilities better
players etc and it's all because of the
bitcoin standard when we think about
these english
football teams how big can this be if
he's able to capture a global audience
versus like one of the smaller teams
that just has more of a local audience
well if you can
turn into a premier league club you make
a lot of money
relative to the 10th league for sure
but it's obviously hard to do otherwise
everyone would do it i think working
your way up is obviously one sustainable
model but these teams like peter i'm
assuming there's not much of a uh a
global audience now right it's super
centralized to bedford so if you have
the ability to go out and reach all the
bitcoiners around the world that creates
a lot of opportunities for you guys
right yeah i mean yeah look in in the
first week week or two weeks of doing
this we already got like 10 000
followers on twitter which is already
more than the local rivals
um i've had 50 people register to run
international supporters clubs i've got
people from ghana australia
all over the us
turkey
new zealand people who are saying we
want to get behind this team let me
register supporters club stream the
games for us we'll get people together
to do this
so i think the thing is about this is
the thing about like we're in this
unique position that
we have this crazy army of bitcoiners
who get behind anything that's bitcoin
so the examples i'll give you two
examples
prior to michael saylor yeah doing this
bitcoin thing no one really knew the
microstrategy was no one really knew
what michael said it was now every ceo
in america knows who michael sailor is
everyone knows their strategy el
salvador before buckley did what he did
nobody would well nobody would be able
to name the president of el salvador and
probably could even point you on a map
now everyone knows who he is this is
exactly the same we are the
microstrategy we are the el salvador of
sports
and my other question would be like i
know these clubs are uh they're
entrenched within the communities right
like people care about it a lot see
people are sensitive to it what's the
reaction been from people are they like
super happy that this is happening are
they upset did they think you're messing
around like
what have people said to you
everyone involved with the club that i'm
buying
loves it and gets behind it they think
it's great
every one of our neighbors
uh well not everyone but our neighbors
uh bedford town they're not happy
a lot of people in football hate it
because i'm trying to do things a little
bit different right
you know i'm naming them real bedford
like real madrid i think it's funny and
uh i've made the logo a skull just
because you know i've got a skull on my
hat it's goals are cool like i'm just
there's some there's some an american
tinge to the brand because i'm aware of
where the audience is you know there is
a local audience but there is an
international audience i've been saying
to these people look just think about
this for a second this is a club that
ran on 15 000 pounds i've already closed
500 thousand pound sponsorship i'm
probably going to do 1.5 million in
revenue i can't spend that on the team
but what i can do because like there's
nowhere spending all that money you know
the most i'll spend is maybe a hundred
grand so what can i do i could start a
women's team i could start a reserve
team i could start youth teams and i can
build up grassroots football investment
yeah i can create economic opportunity
and support grassroots probably invest
like why would you hate this what
because you don't like our badge or
because you think it's we've got an
american audience it's just [ __ ]
like this also yeah
swear but this is an opportunity you
know to support my town and to create
opportunity for the people who live here
so yeah
i really don't care if people get upset
by it john what questions you got
peter so i was just curious about like
when you came in in your icloud core
going on bitcoin standard i'm the new
owner
what was one people's responses and two
if someone didn't want to do that are
you still giving them the option for
um the pound or to get paid in whatever
currency or is it like hey you have to
get paid in bitcoin you can convert it
if you want but you you are getting paid
in bitcoin no that's a really good
question like i am not forcing the
bitcoin thing down to people's throat
one of the interesting things that's
come out of this is it's made me again
aware of how big the jump is from
hearing about bitcoin to understanding
it because there's a lot of people
who've basically lumped us in with the
dell people the crypto pros the
nft people we're not that the bitcoin
standard is how i choose it's the
financial model i choose to run the club
on but nobody is forced to be paid in
bitcoin nobody is forced to accept
bitcoin we you don't have to pay in
bitcoin when you're in our club that's
all optional we are a we are a club that
allows you to
be paid or get paid in the pound or
bitcoin we're not forcing down anyone's
throws the bitcoin standard for us is
how we manage our treasury and how we
manage our finances and that's us